good morning John thanks for a very good
video in reminding me to schedule a
haircut I can always tell when it starts
to invade my ear canal look why are you
going in there I've been going through
the first round of responses to the
nerdfighteria census which is still open
and will be open for a little while
longer it people are taking about 15
minutes to finish it it tells me that so
I know it and if you want to fill it out
just pause the video go do it now it's
very helpful to us and I love reading
the responses just give me a lot of
ideas about my punishment which is
coming up so thank you everybody who
submitted those I'm pretty sure I know
I'm gonna do now you've gotta be
unpleasant I've also of course been
reading people's longer text responses
about like what we're doing and maybe
what you'd like us to do differently one
person wanted there to be pizza mist
merge without John's weird face on it
and look I understand that perspective
it makes perfect sense sorry I agree
it's weird face but there we are a much
more common theme than that people want
to not be a burden on us it seems like
people are afraid that you are a burden
and that we are stressed out and you
want to help give us some time off but
that lead to do a pretty consistent
theme there's also a lot of people who
are saying man I liked it better when
you were more freeform and more silly
and less serious and stressed and a lot
of times that comes without the word
stressed that it's like you guys are so
serious now it's easy to take that
feedback and think like well no we do
lots of silly videos still and I don't
really know where you're coming from
with that actually if I think about it
in the frame of that first response that
was really common it does make some
sense because I don't know that it's
about what the topic of the video is
necessarily I think that it might be
more about like us looking stressed out
but like I don't think that you want us
to be in our 20s again I don't think
that you want to flake out on the street
like putting peeps inside of weird punk
rockers though maybe I don't know it's
not gonna happen I think the thought
might be like chill out a little bit
enjoy it I want to see you enjoy the
thing and that makes a lot of sense to
me that actually really rings true to me
if we're stressed out it's gonna come
through no matter what this dress is
about like it could just be about like
of the number of obligations we have
taken on in the last 10 years that
includes like family and life stuff that
includes work in project stuff it also
includes the fact that like 2018
internet is sort of a less carefree vibe
then 2008 internet was also I feel the
responsibility of using the platform
correctly more also I'm just generally
more worried about the future of
humanity now than I was 10 years ago I
don't know if that's because I'm older
or if it's cause of other changes that
have occurred but regardless of the
source of the stress if you can feel it
coming through I would imagine
cuz it's there we're not gonna hide it
John as you said you asked to do I love
every individual thing I'm doing and as
people who listen to dear Hank and John
we'll find out next week John and I
agreed with Kurt Vonnegut when he said
another flaw in the human character is
that everybody wants to build and nobody
wants to do maintenance I don't mind
doing maintenance I just like building
more but I will say that vlogbrothers to
me has never felt like maintenance this
has never felt like oh we got to keep
the thing alive it's just a creative
outlet to do something interesting and
have a little bit of freedom and have
complete control over the process and
not let that fall away the obligation I
feel on this channel isn't ever
frustrating it's just free and just like
it seems like nerdfighter you would like
me to be less stressed I would also like
to be less stressed and while there are
some things that I can't change and some
things that I don't want to change I
think there are some ways for me to be a
little more free I'm honestly not the
kind of guy who thinks that like
achievement is the point of life I see a
lot of people like that and I just don't
understand it I think the point of life
is is joy and beyond that helping other
people find joy so let's do that more
joy in 2019 okay okay John I'll see you
on Tuesday